hey everyone what's up welcome back to
code 30 Kings in 30 days with css3 today
is day number 2 and we're gonna be doing
a lesson that I call sexy typography so
over here in the browser you can see
basically in the final result you can
kind of see what it is we're going to be
building so in css3
what's kind of neat is you can you can
make some really cool text effects just
with css3 you don't need Photoshop or
anything like that so I wanted to
highlight a couple of those things in
css3 in today's lesson it's pretty
simple shouldn't take us too long but I
think it's gonna be fun and might kind
of give you a few ideas of what you can
do with css3 on your own websites and
applications and so on all right so
before we start coding you're gonna need
the course files the final course files
so in this module there's going to be a
lesson entitled download the course
files or whatever it is that I named it
at the time and you could just click on
that link it'll take you to a Dropbox
link it should direct download to that
today's course files which should be
entitled to - sexy typography there will
be an index file a sandbox that CSS file
and a final CSS file and that's what you
need for today the index you don't need
to concern yourself with other than
looking at seeing how the markup is laid
out sandbox says CSS is where you're
going to be coding your own CSS and then
the final CSS is what you're going to
use for reference it gives you the final
result over here in the browser you
could see down here you can use it for
reference that's what we're gonna try to
build the final CSS is what gets you
that result okay so go ahead and
download that you can pause the video do
whatever you need to do and once you're
done with that come back open it up in
your code editor and let's get started
so first things first in your sandbox
that CSS open up a new line and let's
get coding so we need to code the first
example here cool shadow I call it
basically has this cool retro shadow
that kind of offsets behind and off to
the bottom right of the text and it's
this cool effect and that's purely CSS
so let's do that it's pretty
straightforward and simple all you got
to do is select that class so in our
index
I know what it's called shadow typo is
the class I called it Shadow - typo and
then we're going to position that
relative
like so now we're gonna
display:inline-block and font size we
need to make that quite large so for em
in fact let's make it for Ren to be
consistent with css3
text transform we want that to be up or
case all uppercase the color let's go
double O B 3 B 4 and and then here's
where the magic happens so let me just
save this and head over here to the
browser we're basically halfway there
we're actually 99% of the way there it
looks pretty much the same as down here
although for RIM made this quite a bit
smaller so me head back to our code
editor maybe make that something like
six RAM let's see what that does
okay go back it's a little bit big but
whatever you want to do it's up to you
now all we need to do is add a text
shadow in css3 but to text shadows so
we're gonna have a transparent text
shadow behind the letters and then
another text shadow behind that one it
gives that kind of separation so head
back here to your CSS your sandbox does
CSS and we're going to go text shadow
three pixels three pixels that's
vertical and horizontal offset three
pixels and three pixels so we're gonna
go down and over zero pixels we don't
want any blur and the number is gonna be
e 7ee F 1 that is this color of the
background container so it's gonna
you're not gonna see anything at all on
purpose comma one more value in here 8
pixels 8 pixels to walk off setting this
8 pixels down and 8 pixels over and then
the blur 0 we don't want any blur on
this whatsoever and then we're gonna do
RGB a for red green blue alpha and 0 0 0
so this is like gonna give us black but
then the Alpha Channel zero point 1
which is gonna make it like 10% so it's
going to be very very transparent so I'm
gonna be 10% visible semicolon save that
head over to your browser and you can
see you're done just like that pretty
cool
text shadow effect you've got that you
can see here you got that 3 pixel offset
and then the 8 pixel offset okay so that
was it for the cool shadow
let's go down to the 3d type we're gonna
make a bit of a three-dimensional effect
so over here in the browser this one's
kind of cool it's angled it's got this
like depth and then like kind of a layer
at the back that's a bit darker so you
can see here you got the text on an
angle a bit of a depth going on there
like it pops out and then there's like a
layer at the back that's darker and then
this like very subtle shadow it's very
simple
we're just be playing with some
transforms and some text shadow very
simple so let's go back here to our code
editor sandbox on CSS alright so we're
going to select that class and that's
going to be called 3d typo I'm tight I
wrote 3d literally because you can't
start a class with a number so just put
3d 3d - typo like that and then we're
gonna start with the font size let's do
six REM again and then we're going to
say text transform uppercase and then
the color is gonna be f two three nine
five eight and then we're gonna do some
transform so I'm going to start off with
the transform here and then we're gonna
say skew is the first value of the
transform property skew
and then to valiums x and y minus 5
degrees , -5 degrees that's gonna angle
it and then we're gonna rotate it five
degrees whoops that's got to be
connected just like that so if I save
that and check it out over here in the
browser basically looks like it's italic
but you can see when I highlight it my
cursor highlight is actually on an angle
and when you highlight text that's
italic it doesn't necessarily do that so
so this is actually being angled and
rotated a little bit if I were to be a
bit more dramatic you would see you know
that this is actually so I'm gonna
rotate it even more like 25 degrees so
check it out you can see that that's
what I'm doing so I'm gonna put that
back to 5 degrees on the rotate and then
I'm gonna do the degrees 5 negative 5
and negative 5 and we're good to go okay
so now because transform is css3
sometimes some browsers don't
necessarily know what that is so we got
to use browser prefixes you can check
out can I use comm and see how valid
transform property is in css3 and how
cross-browser compatible it is but I'm
just going to for good practice put in
WebKit transform and essentially just
copy this it's a it's exactly the same
thing and just paste that in so same
thing save it and now let's keep going
so we're going to do the transform
origin so I want to change is the origin
of where it rotates and where it's
transforming because I'm pretty sure
currently it goes from the top left I
think that's the default transform
origin so where it transforms from and
where it rotates from so that's that you
can change where you want that origin to
be so I'm gonna say Center Center so
save that you would notice this more if
I change the values of the skew and the
rotate to something more dramatic you'd
see that it's rotating from the center
so why don't I give you an example of
that so I'm gonna comment this out 20
and 20 so if I were to say bottom right
and save and go back here you can see
it's actually the origin is in a
separate spot versus like top
left and then go back here you can see
now it's in a different spot so it's
actually or the origin of the transform
is in different positions of the element
so we want Center Center so it's nice
and centered perfect now back in the
code editor here we're gonna copy this
but then have the browser prefix version
transform origin but it's gonna be
WebKit transform origin and now we need
to just do some text shadows it's very
simple we're just gonna do a lot of text
shadows in one text shadow property here
so text shadow we're gonna say one pixel
one pixel we've done this before D 10 e
31 I'm gonna copy that value because I'm
gonna use it a lot now if I stopped
there you wouldn't see much over here
it's just a slight darker shadow behind
it so let me save this oh I'm gonna
change this back to five degree five all
around perfect okay so I'm gonna put a
comma and return go back and under here
and I'm gonna do another couple values
two pixels two pixels I'm gonna paste
that value here copy this I'm gonna put
a comma and we're gonna change this from
two and two to three and three now you
catch the idea I'm gonna do this up
until seven so just do that there we go
so save that send e colon at the end
check it out and see what we got so far
perfect it's got that kind of angled
depth kind of it pops out looks great
but there's still more to it we have
another layer so let's go back here to
our editor comma I'm gonna paste and
change this to eight and eight but
change the color value to a darker
salmony red color which is gonna be
eight 909 - OH
copy that value paste it a couple more
times we're gonna change this to nine
and the nine and ten and ten semicolon
at the end
check it out in your browser we
basically finished it but there's one
little element left and that's just kind
of those broad blur in the background
you could see it as the final example
there's a bit of a background shadow an
actual shadow back there that just gives
it more depth it pops out more than up
here so let's go back here and add one
more value so a comma we're going to go
11 pixels
eleven pixels but for the blur property
15 pixels so quite blurry very blurry in
fact an RGBA we're gonna do zero zero
zero which is black but then another
comma now we need the Alpha Channel
we're gonna go 0.5 which is 50%
transparent semicolon save that head
back over and there we are in the
browser we're done 3d type we've got
that depth I've got that little layer
there that's darker and then the shadow
in the background so we've got the cool
shadow the retro-style shadow there and
then we've got the 3d type that pops out
using text shadow so it's quite simple
but it's just a matter of playing around
with the values and and giving the
illusion that you have three-dimensional
text so all of this is done in css3
exclusively just you know a dozen or so
lines of CSS very simple whereas if you
were to do this in photoshop you'd have
to make it in Photoshop you'd have to
export it for like retina and normal and
then put the images and you're adding
more bandwidth and it just takes too
long just to create something you could
just do simply in css3 so that is it for
day 2 sexy typography a little bit
simpler of a day today then yesterday
day one was quite the beast but today is
simpler just to kind of give you a
better breathing room before we get into
some pretty awesome and difficult stuff
as we go along in this journey
hope you enjoyed day two I'll see you
tomorrow number
beast Cheers gotta go bye
[Music]